La neve che cade sopra di me copre tutto col suo oblio
In questo remoto regno la regina sono io
Le vent qui hurle en moi ne pense plus à demain
Il est bien trop fort J'ai lutté en vain
No dejes que sepan de ti
"que no entren" siempre me dijo a mi
"lo has de sentir no han de saber"
¡ya que más da!
Let it go, let it go
Can't hold it back anymore
Turn away and slam the door
Es ist Zeit, nun bin ich bereit!
Und ein Sturm zieht auf
Die Kälte, sie ist nun ein Teil von mir
Eu vejo que a distância vai tudo suavizar
E os medos de outros tempos não me vão apanhar
E timpul meu sa ma pornesc,
Sa vad ce pot, ce reusec
Sa fie numai cum vreau eu, mereu!
Livre estou, livre estou
Com o céu e o vento andar
Não vão me ver chorar
Sóc aquí!
I no em mouran!
Deixa el vent cridar
Lai šaltis valdo visą žemę šia gale
Sustingus mano siela šalto ledo kristale
Et mes pensées sont des fleurs de cristal gelée
ya no regresaré el pasado ya pasó
Io lo so, sì lo so, come il sole tramonterò
Ich bin frei, endlich frei
Was war ist jetzt vorbei
Here I stand in the light of day
Let the storm rage on
Da oggi il destino appartiene a me